On en parle avec Stéphane Caron,
porte-parole de la Société
de protection des forêts contre
le feu (SOPFEU).
Bonsoir. C'est une mission de 14
jours qui attend les pompiers de
la SOPFEU. Qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire exactement sur place?
- Ils vont connaître leur
assignation en arrivant en
Colombie-Britannique et ils vont
faire essentiellement le même
type de travail qu'ils font au
Québec, c'est-à-dire de la
suppression d'incendie au sol
avec différentes techniques
qu'on peut utiliser. Au Québec,
on utilise beaucoup l'eau, mais
il y a différentes autres
techniques qui peuvent être
utilisées.
- Les méthodes peuvent être très
différentes en Colombie-
Britannique dans certains cas?
- Il y a différentes techniques
qui sont utilisées dans le monde
et les agences qui font de la
suppression d'incendie vont
choisir les techniques les plus.
Au Québec, tout le monde a en
tête les avions citernes parce
qu'on a des laques partout. Les
avions peuvent se ravitailler
facilement et à être très
efficace, ce qui empêche pas que
les verrait travail ça fait au
sol par les pompiers forestiers.
On va travailler aux outils
manuels pour remuer le sol,
creuser des tranchées et faire
des coups. On va aussi utiliser
le feu, combattre le feu par le
feu, brûler du combustible au
sol pour priver le feu qui s'en
vient des matières à brûler.
- Donc combattre le feu par le
feu pour mieux contrôler
finalement sur le terrain?
- Tout à fait et ce qui est
intéressant dans ces échanges,
au-delà du fait qu'on s'en va
aider un partenaire qui en a
bien besoin, nos gens reviennent
grandi de cette expérience,
parce qu'ils vont mettre à
profit des nouvelles techniques.
Au Québec, on peut après sa s'en
servir, évaluer les situations,
peut-être changer les façons de
faire. C'est une occasion
d'apprendre pour la SOPFEU en se
prêtant.
- On a vu à quel point la
situation est difficile en
Colombie-Britannique
présentement. Est-ce que les
pompiers de la SOPFEU qui y
vont, qui sont en route
présentement vont s'exposer à
des risques dans cette mission?
- La sécurité, c'est
prioritaire.
On ne va pas mettre la vie de
nos gens en danger pour
combattre un incendie de forêt.
C'est vraiment prioritaire. Il y
a des spécialistes en
comportements d'incendie qui
vont prévoir le comportement de
l'incendie. On laissera pas des
pompiers travail à des endroits
où ça pourrait être dangereux.
Évidemment, c'est pas sans
risque, mais on fait tout ce
qu'il faut et c'est la même
chose en Colombie-Britannique
pour pas mettre nos pompiers à
risque.
- L'état d'esprit doit être
différent également avec ce qui
s'est passé à Ltton j'imagine
que vos hommes et vos femmes
peut-être aussi de la SOPFEU,
les pompiers qui seront là
auront ça en tête également
qu'il y a un village entier qui
a été rasé par les flammes et la
semaine dernière.
- Au Québec, c'est pas quelque
chose qui arrive si souvent
qu'on a des catastrophes comme
ça qui vont coucher des
villages. Les évacuations sont
plutôt rares. Nos grands feux
sont souvent dans le nord du
Québec où il y a peu de
populations.
On est habitué de combattre pour
protéger la matière, cette
ressource naturelle que les
bois. Mais là, on est vraiment
dans une situation où il y a des
populations qui sont menacées et
on connaît l'ampleur de la
situation, ce qui faisait dire à
certains pompiers qui partaient
aujourd'hui : oui, c'est une
belle expérience qu'il sent
mauvais, mais en même temps, ils
ne sont pas insensibles. Ils ne
peuvent pas juste se réjouir de
cette expérience qu'ils vont
vivre, parce qu'il savent le
drame qui est derrière ce qui se
passe en Colombie-Britannique.
- Avec les chaleurs extrêmes
qu'on a connues, les changements
climatiques également qui ont
allumé ses feux. Est-ce qu'on
doit s'attendre à vivre sa de
plus en plus au pays?
- Ce qu'on observe depuis un
certain nombre d'années, on
n'est pas des escaliers sans
changement climatique, mais il y
a des observations qui sont
faites par les chercheurs et à
la SOPFEU, on se croit à la
science. On voit très bien que
dans toute la côte ouest de la
Californie jusqu'aux provinces
de l'Ouest et au Canada, il y a
vraiment un changement qui
s'opère dans les dernières
années. Les incendies sont de
plus en plus nombreux, de plus
en plus intenses et font de plus
en plus de dommages. En ce
moment au Québec, on n'observe
pas encore ça parce que
géographiquement, on n'est pas
situé au même endroit et l'effet
des réchauffements climatiques
ne se fait pas sentir de la même
façon partout sur la planète.
Cependant, ce que les chercheurs
le disent, c'est
qu'éventuellement avec la
poursuite de ce réchauffement,
ce qui se passe ailleurs
pourrait finir par nous
rattraper. Donc nous, dans ce
malheur, on a quand même la
chance au niveau des incendies
de forêt de pouvoir voir venir
les choses et de pouvoir s'y
préparer.
- L'occasion justement de mieux
se formait à ses interventions.
Quand on permet un déploiement
comme celui-là, de permettre à
des pompiers du Québec de partir
dans une autre province, c'est
que la situation ici est stable
présentement. Elle est
stabilisée parce qu'on a parlé
beaucoup de sécheresses ces
dernières semaines. Est-ce que
ça va mieux?
- Oui effectivement on a eu un
printemps très actif à la
SOPFEU. Beaucoup de feu au
printemps. Il y a eu quand même
passablement de précipitation
qui ont amené un danger
d'incendie à diminuer. On fait
ces évaluations avant de donner
le feu vert pour le déploiement
de ressources. On sait que pour
les deux prochaines semaines,
selon nos calculs, on est très
capable d'absorber la charge de
travail au Québec même sans les
40 pompiers. Il en reste encore
quelque dizaines, on n'en a 250
au total plus de la main-
d'oeuvre, des employés
auxiliaires qui sont quand même
400 environ.
- Très bien, on va suivre la
mission de la SOPFEU pour les
deux prochaines semaines. Fort
intéressant Stéphane Caron ce
que nous avons vous nous avez
partag